no
we'll have to wait a couple of months to
get 70s all the way through the day but
yeah 70s in the morning hours normal low
is 81. so really we have to i guess
count our lucky stars that we were in
the 70s and with drier air it just feels
so good we got a lot of valley
neighborhoods in the 70s again this
morning really only a couple green
valley downtown in the 80s right now
even 60s out at red rock and 59 up there
at kyle canyon so we are definitely
cooler than normal low 70's in sandy
valley 70 in prom 66 in indian springs
76 in mesquite look at that 54 up in
cedar city 58 in caliente 48 in elay
tonopah just under 60 degrees same as
reno we've got 82 in laughlin 73 in
kingman and mid-70s boulder city and
mesquite this morning of course boulder
city having the big danbury parade
yesterday too and all the fun in boulder
city so i'm sure
it was a lot of great stuff going on
there and hopefully everybody had a safe
safe fourth of july extreme to
exceptional drought for central and
southern nevada the latest drought
monitor just came out right at the end
of the month last week i'm just
reiterating and just wanting to show you
how exceptionally dry we are over all i
mean all of clark county now is in the
exceptional status for severe drought so
we are so dry but even nye county
lincoln county both areas also in
extreme to exceptional drought the
monsoon is still active from el paso
over to the four corners a few showers
even up into colorado a new system
moving into the pacific northwest
bringing some rain up there and
thunderstorms over the northern rockies
and plains and we've got showers and
thunderstorms in the ohio valley but all
these areas of kind of orange peach
orange and deep red to neon pink
these are heat alerts and heat warnings
with hazy hot humid conditions about a
dozen states or more under all of those
heat alerts millions of people there
sweating it out today in the southwest
we'll stay dry breezy southwest winds
again picking up today for your tuesday
we'll look for nearly 100 degrees we
were 99 yesterday that's what we're
looking for for your tuesday dry breezy
winds 25 miles an hour this afternoon
and again tomorrow
south to southeast breezes at times into
wednesday and thursday and then the
winds calm down and the temperatures
rise up back to normal 105 107 even
above normal for the weekend early next
week maybe even 110 plus on tuesday ouch